[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
[Musik]
guten abend das ist ein wahlabend ein
spannender dazu in frankreich auf die
ergebnisse schauen wir gleich zunächst
aber nach berlin dort trat vor einer
halben stunde die
bundesfamilienministerin eine spiegel
vor die presse und ihr auftritt war
bemerkenswert die grünen politikerin war
letzten sommer noch umweltministerin in
rheinland pfalz und dass sie als solche
unangemessen mit der
hochwasserkatastrophe dort umgegangen
sei sogar noch einen langen urlaub
gemacht hatte diese vorwürfe wurden
immer drängender und nun an der spiegel
trat nicht zurück sondern räumte fehler
ein die sie mit ihrer privaten situation
mit der erkrankung ihres mannes etwa
begründete wie gesagt ein
bemerkenswerter auftritt
das war ein fehler dass wir
auch so langen urlaub gefahren sind und
dass wir in urlaub gefahren sind
und ich bitte
für diesen fehler
um entschuldigung ich habe nicht aus
meinem urlaub heraus an den
kabinettssitzung teilgenommen aber ich
möchte betonen dass ich die ganze zeit
erreichbar war ich habe mit der
ministerpräsidentin gesprochen ich habe
mit meinen staatssekretären gesprochen
telefoniert ich möchte mich
für die fehler
ausdrücklich
entschuldigen
ja in berlin ist theo koll das ganze
natürlich auch beobachtet hatte das ist
ja doch wirklich ungewöhnlich in der
bundespolitik mann hatte in der
vergangenheit schon
tränenreiche rücktritte erlebt aber so
emotional auch vom privatleben zu
berichten und auch um verständnis zu
bitten ist ja durchaus neu ja ich muss
gestehen ich bin jetzt seit fast 40
jahren journalist aber das habe ich noch
nie erlebt hatte eine ministerin unter
politischem druck und den gab es ja
privateste dinge offen gelegt also
erzählt vom schlaganfall ihres mannes
der keinem stress meer ausgesetzt werden
da von den vier kleinen kindern die
nicht gut durch die korona pandemie
gekommen sind hat eine ministerin mit
sehr privaten informationen ein jahr als
politisches versagen empfundenes eigenes
handeln erklärt das war menschlich
ergreifen muss ich sagen und auch die
brutalität des politischen geschäfts
sehr klar machen dass keine rücksicht
auf private probleme nimmt aber ob das
ausreicht die kritik zum schweigen zu
bringen da würde ich ein fragezeichen
setzen denn unter anderem hat die
ministerin ja auch ausgeführt dass sie
gestern offensichtlich bei einem polen
besuch auf anfrage einer großen
sonntagszeitung bestätigt hat dass sie
im urlaub an den kabinettssitzungen
teilgenommen hat das aber habe sich beim
nachsehen als fehler herausgestellt also
ich muss gestehen ob man wenn man das
sich selber vorstellt ob man die
teilnahme an kabinettssitzungen während
der flut und während des eigenen urlaubs
nicht mehr erinnert da würde ich ein
großes fragezeichen setzen jetzt könnte
man das ganze ja auch ein bisschen
deuten als ein stück politische kultur
änderung politiker politikerinnen in
diesem fall räumt fehler ein und müssen
dann vielleicht auch erwarten können
dass sie dass diese fehler verziehen
werden
sie sagen schon fraglich ob das in
diesem fall passiert aber ein stück
andere kultur auch mit blick auf andere
politiker dieser regierung ist da doch
spürbar absolut also ich glaube das ist
auch ein wichtiger punkt auch ein
herausforderungen und medien an uns
wähler an uns politische beobachter im
insgesamt
aber es hat natürlich den immer auch den
faktor man darf dann keine weiteren
fehler machen in dieser klarstellung
oder in der offenlegung wenn ich meine
wenn wir zurückblicken alleine aus den
aus dem letzten jahr angela merkel hat
die
entscheidungen als großen fehler
bezeichnet damals in der korona pandemie
hat das zurückgenommen carlotta war hat
er gerade erst vor wenigen tagen
vorgeführt wie er innerhalb von
kürzester zeit eine
eine entscheidung die quarantäne
regelung zu verändern wieder verändert
hat also
da ist offensichtlich eine neue kultur
und die fordert auch uns heraus uns alle
aber
wie gesagt man darf dann auch trotzdem
noch weiter genau hinschauen ob da
jemand versucht in anführungsstrichen
das will ich jetzt gar nicht
unterstellen aber sich leicht
herauszureden mit privaten informationen
für die grünen hat es natürlich auch
noch einmal eine besondere bedeutung
wenn man
bedenkt dass wir ja mehrere
kabinettsmitglieder haben mütter mit
kleinen kindern als ministerin und aus
auch da immer um die vereinbarkeit von
beruf und familie geht also auch das ist
eine neue herausforderung
in nordrhein westfalen wo es eine
ähnliche
eine ähnliche lage gab mit der dortigen
umweltministerin die auch während der
flutkatastrophe nach mallorca gefahren
ist und dort gefeiert hatte und länger
blieb als sie eigentlich angegeben hatte
da hat es dazu geführt dass die
ministerin zurückgetreten ist aber auch
da sind die situation etwas anders weil
es ist wahlkampf in nordrhein westfalen
und der ministerpräsident dazu
beigetragen hat dass sie zurückgetreten
ist danke für diese einschätzungen ein
bemerkenswerter auftritt ohne zweifel
der wird weiter diskutiert werden in
berlin da bin ich sicher und sicherlich
auch weiter die verantwortung der
ministerin spiegel und nun nach
frankreich erste runde der
präsidentschaftswahl und der amtsinhaber
im manual makro hat die für sich
entschieden jedenfalls sieht es zunächst
so aus marine le pen die
rechtspopulistin ist ihm aber in den
ersten hochrechnungen nicht zu nah
gekommen das dürfte viele in der eu
zunächst mal erleichtern in die
stichwahl in zwei wochen jedenfalls will
makro als favorit gehen aber noch ist
dieser wahlabend nicht zu ende christel
hass berichtet
sie zählen die letzten sekunden bis zur
ersten hochrechnung und dann riesiger
jubel
emanuel macronix fahren mit 28,1 prozent
der stimmen die zweite in der stichwahl
ist marie le pen neuauflage des duells
von vor fünf jahren bei den makro
anhängern ist der erleichterung fast mit
händen greifbar wir haben es geschafft
mit wichtigen ideen zu überzeugen jetzt
bin ich zuversichtlich was die stichwahl
anbelangt es wäre gut wenn marco in den
nächsten zwei wochen sehr präsent wäre
er hat doch eine sehr gute bilanz
vorzuweisen
zur selben zeit im lager ebenfalls
großer jubel wir werden siegen
skandierten sie
im vergleich zu 2017 hat le pen
dazugewonnen noch nie war der sieg für
sie so greifbar
ich werde die nationale unabhängigkeit
frankreich sicher stellen in allen
bereichen das heißt die franzosen können
in freiheit für sich selbst entscheiden
und ihre interessen verteidigen ich
werde die emigration streng
kontrollieren und die sicherheit für
alle gewährleisten
tränen der enttäuschung bei den
anhängern eines mannes der sich bis
zuletzt hoffnung gemacht hatte so lag
milos der alte haudegen am linken rand
er ist knapp ausgeschieden sein credo
jetzt eine rechtspopulisten als
präsidentin verhindern
ihr dürft keine einzige stimme für volle
pen abgeben ihr dürft keine einzige
stimme für freunde kinder blieben
für le pen dagegen wirbt jetzt ihr
ehemaliger konkurrent der rechtsextreme
erik simon der mit 9 prozent der stimmen
weit abgeschlagen ist es ist das ende
eines wahltags an dem alles hätte
möglich sein können denn der wahlkampf
begleitet von corona und dem ukraine
krieg emanuel makro als präsident
gefragt nicht als kandidat und stieg
erst spät in die kampagne ein
das nutzte marin lippen die sich als
vertreterin der kleinen leute in szene
setzte und das thema kaufkraft in den
vordergrund stellte die wähler heute
tief gespalten
ich habe große angst vor den rechten ich
habe angst vor den extremen le pen und
sem uhr dürfen nicht an die macht kommen
die extreme rechte ist im moment sehr
stark in frankreich ich werde alles
daran setzen dass sie nicht durchkommt
es gibt keinen kandidaten der mich
repräsentiert meine sorgen ernst nimmt
sie sind alle abgehoben frankreich hat
die nase voll
in zwei wochen heißt es jetzt also
micron gegen loeb in politische mitte
gegen rechtsaußen europa freund gegen
europa skeptikerin und obwohl der
amtierende präsident heute vorn liegt
entschieden ist noch nichts
thomas walde in paris beobachtet den
abend natürlich in krisenzeiten
versammeln sich die menschen hinter dem
amtsinhaber und meiden er veränderungen
wird es das sein was man heute abend
dann doch rettet ist es schon ausgemacht
dass er wirklich vorn liegt
also makro list liegt in diesem ersten
wahlgang stabil vorne weg besser als es
die umfragen bis zuletzt angedeutet
hatten und seinen abstand zu lippen ist
auch größer als es die letzten umfragen
angedeutet haben einen effekt dürfte
sein dass er der einzige mainstream
kandidat war der die aussicht hatte in
den zweiten wahlgang zu kommen ansonsten
waren dass populisten von ganz rechts
und ganz links und hatten viele
franzosen offensichtlich angst die iren
die nicht eine radikale veränderung
wollen einige von makros konkurrenten
fordern jetzt dazu auf ihn zu wählen
einige fordern dazu auf le pen zu wählen
interessant wird vor allem sein wie die
linken sich verhalten ob die aktiv in
macau wählen ob sie diese für sie recht
hohe hürde nehmen oder sich enthalten im
lager herrscht große erleichterung
wirklich gerettet bisher noch nicht
heisst also jetzt in der stichwahl
wieder makro gegen le pen aber da hat
sich ja trotzdem thomas was verändert in
der französischen gesellschaft in der
parteienlandschaft auch
ja in der tat man könnte man dass er
dasselbe wie vor fünf jahren aber ganz
so ist es nicht die französische
parteienlandschaft ist im umbruch die
sozialisten und die re publica also das
was in deutschland etwa die spd und die
uni während spielen hierbei
präsidentschaftswahlen keine rolle mehr
und insgesamt haben ist populistische
kandidatinnen und kandidaten auf 50
prozent der stimmen gebracht ganz rechts
und ganz links kandidatin kandidaten die
beispielsweise aus der kommandostruktur
der nato heraus wollen die frankreich
der heraus führen wollen das wird
effekte haben das wird bleiben selbst
wenn makro am ende dann doch im zweiten
wahlgang gewinnen sollte der ist in 14
tagen vielen dank thomas walde nach
paris ja und über die weiteren
hochrechnungen aus frankreich halten wir
sie bei zdf heute auf dem laufenden so
nun zunächst nachrichten mit gundula
gause
als erster westlicher regierungschef
seit kriegsbeginn in der ukraine will
der österreichische bundeskanzler
neheimer morgen in moskau mit kremlchef
putin zusammen kommen aus wien heißt es
ne hammer habe vorab die deutsche
bundesregierung die eu spitzen und den
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
informiert erst gestern war ne hammer in
kiew dabei hatte sie lenski erneut
größeren druck des westens auf moskau
verlangt
mehr einsatz der bundesregierung für die
ukraine hat anton hofreiter gefordert
der vorsitzende des europa ausschusses
im bundestag der grünen-politiker
verlangte in der zdf sendung berlin
direkt dringend die lieferung von
schützenpanzern des typs marder die
bundeswehr solle bis zu 30
funktionsfähige panzer aus ihren
beständen abgeben dies ist laut
verteidigungsministerium lambrecht kaum
möglich
bundesweit haben sich tausende an
solidaritätskundgebungen für die ukraine
beteiligt unter anderem in hannover
osnabrück und in stuttgart in berlin
kamen laut veranstaltern 8500 menschen
zusammen die mehr unterstützung für die
ukraine forderten ex boxweltmeister
wladimir klitschko rief dabei per
videobotschaft zu mehr waffenlieferungen
auf
gleichzeitig hat es auch pro-russische
demonstrationen in mehreren städten
gegeben allerdings mit weniger
teilnehmern gut 800 menschen kamen in
frankfurt am main zusammen in hannover
führen rund 350 autos durch die stadt um
gegen die diskriminierung
russischsprachiger menschen zu
protestieren begleitet wurde der korso
von der polizei die auch verbotene
flagge und symbole kontrollierte
in der ukraine werden immer mehr
gräueltaten aufgedeckt naki vor der
heute ein weiteres massengrab mit
dutzenden opfern entdeckt insgesamt gibt
die ukraine die zahl der in der region
kiew getöteten zivilisten mit
1222 an im osten des landes im donbass
wird eine grossoffensive der russischen
armee erwartet viele menschen in den
regionen von lohans und dann jetzt
versuchen über flucht korridore gen
westen zu kommen der gouverneur von
lohans sagte man gehe nur noch von tagen
aus bis zum vorstoß der russin und
erwarte so wörtlich die hölle auch in hf
bereitet man sich auf die offensive fort
bevor von dort berichtet an ginzel
wir sind unterwegs interaktiv fahren zu
einer wohnsiedlung am stadtrand hier ist
die front nicht weit immer wieder
schlagen russische raketen ein erzählen
uns die männer
vor etwa zwei wochen war der erste
angriff der zweite war genau vor einer
woche am letzten sonntag und heute war
der dritte da drüben da sieht man noch
das loch mitten im haus
bloody mit ricotta lebt jetzt im keller
vor einer woche hat eine rakete sein
haus getroffen das wohnzimmer völlig
zerstört wladimirs frau kam mit schweren
verletzungen ins krankenhaus lag im koma
wie soll es einem gehen wenn man
permanent beschossen wird natürlich habe
ich angst meine frau lebt nicht mehr
heute morgen kam die nachricht aus dem
krankenhaus sagt er uns seine frau ist
an ihren verletzungen gestorben
[Musik]
der stadtteil ist schwer umkämpft
zwischen ukrainer und russen
wir fahren nach abpfiff zum krankenhaus
in dem wladimir frau gestorben ist wir
sind verabredet mit dem sohn er wünscht
sich dass der krieg endlich aufhört der
krieg hat schon so viele menschen das
leben gekostet auch das leben meiner
mama des menschen den ich am meisten
geliebt habe
ein anderes wohngebiet in haag hier ist
gestern eine rakete eingeschlagen
auch hier ist kein militärisches ziel
sichtbar die russischen angriffe treffen
die zivilbevölkerung wanja wohnt hier er
ist 13 und hat in den trümmern einen
splitter einer rakete gefunden
ich gehe nicht mehr zur schule ich
versuche zwar zu lernen aber es klappt
nicht weil wir immer in den keller
fliehen müssen ich habe hier auch keine
freunde mehr die sind alle schon
geflohen
mit ihrer vierjährigen tochter mascha
willner teil ja nicht länger hier
bleiben sie will raus aus der stadt
wir müssen unser haus verlassen und
fliehen ich weiß gar nicht wohin ich so
vor allem frauen und kinder versuchen
rocky iv zu verlassen und richtung
westen zu fliehen sie fürchten eine
offensive der russen in den kommenden
tagen die männer bleiben zurück um ihr
land zu verteidigen
die russische armee geht mit ungeheurer
brutalität vor gegen städte gegen die
zivilbevölkerung mehr als 5600 fälle von
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit habe man inzwischen
identifiziert teilte die ukrainische
generalstaatsanwältin mit bundeskanzler
scholz versprach in einem telefonat mit
präsidentin lenski die bundesregierung
werde alles daran setzen dass die
verbrechen aufgeklärt und die täter zur
verantwortung gezogen würden das ist
schwer genug zu den juristischen
voraussetzungen unsere rechtsexpertin
zarate
wehrlos erschossen mit gefesselten
händen
unbewaffnet schutzlos in zivil
frauen männer kinder einfach ermordet
jede einzelne dieser taten kann ein
kriegsverbrechen sein denn
vergewaltigung folter tötung von
zivilisten sind schwerste straftaten
auch im krieg
und diese mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen
in der ukraine können auch bei uns in
deutschland angeklagt werden hier in
karlsruhe mit bereits der geräte verdi
im ukraine krieg schuldig gemacht hat
normalerweise wäre das deutsche
strafrecht für einen mord den ein russe
an eine ukrainerin in der ukraine
beginnt nicht zuständig wenn das aber
ein kriegsverbrechen sein sollte dann ja
dann ist deutschland zuständig
unabhängig davon wer die tat begeht und
wo sie begangen wird
für diese mutmaßlichen kriegsverbrechen
in der ukraine können in deutschland
aber nur putins kämpfer sicher bestraft
werden er selbst wohl nicht denn solange
russlands präsident putin im amt ist
genießt der nach völkerrechtlichen
grundsätzen in deutschland immunität und
das schützt ihn aktuell davor in
deutschland angeklagt zu werden anders
hier am internationalen strafgerichtshof
in den haag kann putin für
kriegsverbrechen der prozess gemacht
werden
das römische statut erlaubt es bei
kriegsverbrechen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit auch staatsoberhäupter
und auch solche von nicht
vertragsstaaten wie der russischen
föderation vor gericht zu stellen die
wesentliche herausforderung in diesem
zusammenhang sind eben wieder die
praktischen fragen
es ist im moment nicht wahrscheinlich
dass putin so lange im amt ist nach den
haag kommen wird denn hier hin wird
russland ihn nicht ausliefern und der
internationale strafgerichtshof kann
selber keine kriegsverbrecher festnehmen
solange also weder putin noch seine
kämpfer gefasst und ausgeliefert werden
kann ihn hier nicht der prozess gemacht
werden auch deshalb ist eine zentrale
frage
will russland mit dem krieg gegen die
ukraine mit vergewaltigung misshandlung
und morden sein bruder folgt die ukraine
zerstören begeht also russland im
juristischen sinn ein völkermord einen
genozid an den ukrainern
es ist diese zerstörungs absicht die
eben nachzuweisen ist wenn man einen
völkermord an den juristisch im
juristischen sinne einen völkermord
anklagen und aburteilen möchte ob es
hierfür von russischer seite für eine
solche zerstörung absicht etwa gegenüber
der ukrainischen bevölkerung schon
hinreichende anhaltspunkte gibt da habe
ich ehrlich gesagt zweifel und diese
zweifel werden aktuell am zweiten großen
gericht in den haag geklärt denn hier am
internationalen gerichtshof verklagt die
ukraine russland wegen völkermordes hier
gehen staaten gegen staaten vor nicht
putin nicht seine kämpfer sondern
russland sitzt hier auf der anklagebank
drei wege also verbrechen im krieg zu
verurteilen die juristischen
voraussetzungen sind da doch erst ein
bisschen beweise gesichert und
mutmaßliche kriegsverbrecher gefasst
werden
soweit die juristische betrachtung
fragen wir jetzt den historiker
professor sönke neitzel besetzt an der
uni potsdam deutschlands einzigen
lehrstuhl für militärgeschichte wir
erreichen ihn in london schon genannt
die nun abgeschlossen professor wir
haben gerade das wort zerstörungs
absicht gehört als bedingung für den
vorwurf des völkermords was sagen sie
als historiker ist hier ein völkermord
ein genozid im gange
also es ist sicherlich die absicht
russlands doch allem was wir heute
wissen den ukrainischen staat zu
zerstören die große frage ist aber gibt
es auch die absicht die ukraine zu
zerstören und sind schon umzubringen
oder teile des ukrainischen volkes
umzubringen da würde ich heute stand
heute noch ein fragezeichen
aber wenn man die bilder aus mario pohl
oder aus butter und anderen orten sieht
wo die russische armee wieder abgezogen
ist scheint ja doch die absicht von der
sie sprechen die intention doch terror
zu sein gegen die bevölkerung jedenfalls
nicht die absicht nur die ukrainischen
kämpfer auszuscheiden
das ist richtig aber die wenn wir jetzt
erklären wollen warum wie können solche
dinge wie in butter passieren da müssen
wir drei faktoren auseinander halten
nämlich die frage welche befehle wurden
gegeben ist von oben wie von unten von
einheitsführer zweitens welche
dispositionen haben die täter auch ihre
einheiten es ist ja auch ein regiment
dort offenbar gewesen dass schon vorher
im tschetschenien krieg gekämpft hat und
drittens können situationen
kriegsverbrechen erklären fast alle
menschen können in bestimmten
situationen schlimme dinge tun und diese
drei faktoren müssen wir zusammen
betrachten also man kann aus dem
historischen wissen und kriegsverbrechen
heraus diese verbrechen in butter diese
schlimmen vorfälle das ist ja macht es
ja nicht besser erklären mit diesen drei
faktoren wie die genaue zusammenspiel
das wissen wir noch nicht und nicht
jedes kriegsverbrechen ist ein genozid
das macht es nicht besser aber nicht
jedes kriegsverbrechen aber nicht dass
im bus eingehen und seien sie sagen
diese position nun weiß man krieg führt
auf jeden fall zur verrohung
sie haben ja dazu auch geforscht unter
anderem mit ihrem buch von 2020 deutsche
krieger also brutalität ist keine sache
nur der russischen soldaten aber haben
wir es hier dann doch mit einer
besonderen dimension zu tun
ja das ist so die frage ich würde sehr
davor warnen dass wir jetzt von in
anführungsstrichen den russischen
soldaten sprechen
wenn wir uns auf die geschichte mal die
geschichte betrachten zwanzigsten
jahrhundert also muss ich in meinem buch
dargestellt habe zur wehrmacht etwa dann
wissen wir um die gewalt disposition der
wehrmacht dass sie eben exzessiv gewalt
angewandt hat also kriegsverbrechen sind
eben über leider überhaupt nichts
außergewöhnliches und wenn wir uns die
situation anschauen in denen
kriegsverbrechen geschehen sind das
immer wieder sehr ähnliche situation der
frustration der angst
situation des koreakrieges aber ich
glaube schon dass nicht alle armeen
gleich sind auch im 20 jahrhundert kann
man unterscheiden und auch im 21
jahrhundert kam unterscheiden und es
gibt schon eine gewisse disposition der
russischen streitkräfte zu gewalt das
haben wir in afghanistan sind in 80
bands und 80er jahren das haben wir im
tschetschenien krieg gesehen im
georgienkrieg 2008 und das sehen wir
jetzt wieder also es gibt schon so würde
ich argumentieren bei den russischen
streitkräften eine gewalt disposition 1
1 footprints zur entgrenzung der gewalt
professor sechs wochen krieg in der
ukraine eine neue offensive der
russischen armee im osten wird ja
erwartet erwartet wie ist ihre
einschätzung kann die ukraine diesen
krieg wirklich gewinnen oder ist das
auch ein stück weit wunschdenken hier im
westen
also es ist schwer von uns hier zum
schreibtisch aus das zu beurteilen
mir scheint es schwierig zu sein die
vorstellung dass die ukraine es schaffen
wird die russischen streitkräfte von
ihrem territorium zur gänze zu
vertreiben die große unbekannte ist die
frage welchen gefechts wert haben die
russischen streitkräfte jetzt noch die
alle haben vor dem 24 februar die
russischen streitkräfte sehr hoch
eingeschätzt aufgrund der reformen in
den russischen streitkräften
das hat sich als irrtum erwiesen und die
frage ist wie weit schaffen das
russische die russischen generäle ist
jetzt wirklich auf den punkt zu kommen
ein gefechts wert zu entfalten der dann
möglicherweise auch es schafft in teile
der ukrainischen armee einzukesseln und
auszuschalten das ist eine offene frage
was gegen die russischen streitkräfte
spricht ist dass es wahrscheinlich keine
überraschung gibt weil die westlichen
nato staaten die ukraine mit mit
satellitenfotos
nachrichtendienstlichen informationen
versorgen einig ist die
grundvoraussetzung auch üben die
überraschung und nur allein mit material
überlegenheit glaube es wäre dass
russland nicht schaffen die ukrainische
armee auszuschalten
dankeschön für die erläuterung heute
abend dankeschön professor
neuzugang
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet und jetzt nochmal
nachrichten
in buchenwald bei weimar haben
überlebende und angehörige sowie
vertreter aus gesellschaft und politik
an die befreiung des
ns-konzentrationslagers vor 77 jahren
erinnert unter ihnen die 96 jährige
anastasia gully aus der ukraine
die überlebende des lagers auschwitz ist
nach dem russischen angriff nach
deutschland geflohen in buchenwald waren
bis 1945 rund
280.000 menschen inhaftiert
56.000 starben dort am elften april 1945
war das konzentrationslager von us
soldaten befreit worden
zum sport in der fußball bundesliga hat
der tabellen vierte rb leipzig am abend
hoffenheim mit 3 zu 0 besiegt eintracht
frankfurt unterlag freiburg 1 2 die
breisgauer damit auf platz fünf der
tabelle und aufsteiger bochum oder
tabellendritte bayer leverkusen trennten
sich torlos
ferrari-pilot charles' claire hat im
dritten formel 1 rennen der saison
souverän den zweiten sieg eingefahren
beim großen preis von australien feierte
der franzose einen start ziel sieg der
auch nach der safety car phase und im
angriff von weltmeister verstappen
ungefährdet blieb fast ab entschied
später mit einem defekt aus am ende
neben erkläre auf dem treppchen red bull
pilot sergio perez als zweiter und
george russell im mercedes auf platz
drei
zum sonntag gehört der ausblick auf die
kommende woche die karwoche steht an vor
ostern das heißt für viele urlaub aber
es gibt auch interessante termine die
wichtigsten hat erik in den sehr
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
schutz vor gefahren im und aus dem all
kommt demnächst aus darmstadt die
europäische weltraumorganisation will am
dienstag ihr neues zentrum zur weltraum
sicherheit in betrieb nehmen mit ihm
sollen satelliten im all wie auch
kritische infrastruktur am boden
beispielsweise stromnetze besser
geschützt werden vor sogenannte
weltraumwetter asteroiden oder
weltraumschrott
wann kommt die zinswende am donnerstag
schauen spare und finanzexperten
neugierig nach frankfurt am main der
europäische zentralbank rat wird nach
seiner zweitägigen zinssitzung am
donnerstag verkünden wie es mit
anleihekäufen und den drei zinsen weiter
geht wichtige signale für explodierende
energiepreise und eine galoppierende
inflation
die friedensbewegung in deutschland
bekommt durch den krieg in der ukraine
wie der neuen zulauf im ganzen land sind
protestmärsche für das osterwochenende
angemeldet die meisten für sonst an
dabei soll es auch kritik geben
waffenlieferungen oder dem geplanten
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr
fehlen noch die wetteraussichten für
diese woche die erfreulich sind es wird
sonnig und wärmer
nur im nordosten morgen einen mix aus
wolken und etwas sonne sonst überwiegt
sonnenschein im norden und osten 8 bis
14 grad im westen und süden 14 bis 19
grad und danach würde es noch wärmer am
mittwoch bis 24 grad dazu viel sonne am
donnerstag aber auch schauer und
gewitter
zum schluss blicken wir noch gemeinsam
auf eine kunstaktion die von lemberg
über paris heute nach düsseldorf kam
solidarität mit der ukraine das will der
französische street art künstler dieses
werks erreichen sein großplakat zeigt
die fünfjährige valeria die anfang märz
aus der zentral ukraine fliehen musste
und jetzt in warschau lebt von rund 100
menschen entrollt ist sie ein symbol für
die unschuld der opfer in diesem
brutalen krieg und wer sie sieht wünscht
dass sie schnell in ihre heimat
zurückkehren kann in frieden
und damit verabschieden wir uns die
nächsten nachrichten gibt es hier in
einer heute express um 0.30 oder immer
auf zdf heute und morgen begrüßen sie an
dieser stelle marietta slomka und heinz
wolf schön armut
[Musik]
das große ziel musik zu erlernen darf
kein privileg sein viele kinder sind
sozial benachteiligt ein gemeinsames
konzert mein großer traum ist in der
welt